true statement that is not true
that is a lie keep clapping you jerks
happy thursday everyone we got a great
show for you plus an evil special guest
but first the monologue you know how bad
joe was yesterday even cnn had to break
character which is like one of the
guards at buckingham palace giving you
the finger
i think you have to be honest that you
can be a foggy meandering a president
say like reagan near the end if you're
winning but if you're foggy and
meandering on key questions and you're
also not winning
then you've got a real problem the first
part was probably the most jarring
to hear a president of the united states
who is not donald trump even suggests
ahead of time that an election isn't
legitimate
and even over at msnbc where they
applaud joe every time he makes a boom
boom within 10 feet of the bathroom
their butt head at large was broken
it was a terrible moment in the press
conference
when he talked about a minor incursion
there is no minor incursion putin
and she and our nato allies are not
debating that right now they see joe
biden as weak yesterday's press
conference did not help if you're
vladimir putin you pay attention to the
cleanup um
minor incursion that's my straight edge
hardcore band
of course there are still holdouts
they're like those japanese pilots from
world war ii stuck on some island cut
off from reality and like their planes
this president is a zero yamiche
alcindor had a kiss-ass tweet
championing joe for not lashing out at
reporters
i guess she was distracted by peter
ducey's hair when this happened
no i didn't say that look what i said go
back and read what i said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
that had to be the creepiest thing joe's
done in the last 48 hours and this is a
man who sniffs children's hair the way
his son snorts parmesan cheese
yamiche also praised joe for making news
which he did he lasted 90 minutes and he
didn't lose consciousness once but he
also green lit a russian invasion so
maybe making news
shouldn't be the priority alec baldwin's
been making news too but it's not good
news but hey he gave it a shot
fact is the one thing americans care
least about besides the voting bill is
what putin's doing and yet that's all
the media cared about while ignoring
real concerns like rampant crime which
should be easy to cover at cnn the sex
crimes unit stops by there twice a day
but the press is more disconnected from
american concerns than pelosi is from
the dollar store
meanwhile walking looney bin jen rubin
gave joe an a-minus
which makes sense if the a stands for
ambulatory i wonder what else she'd
given a minus two
shingles
the olive gardens hot dog bolognese a
blind date with andrew cuomo
i did love how joe kept asking what his
opponents are for
the fundamental question is
what's mitch 4
what's he for
on immigration
what's he for
what's he proposing
to making better
what's he for what's he for
on these things what are they for i tell
my republican friends
here i come
this is going to be about what are you
for
what are you for what are they for
they me one thing they're for oh my god
that was strange
all the answers are obvious you hear
them every day if you're awake maybe
he's not
normal people will tell you what they're
for and it's not four more years of
weakness fear and reckless spending we
want the crime wave to end we want real
borders we want ourselves restocked we
want law and order restored we want to
get back to life
we want the opposite of anywhere
democrats are in charge or at least
stock the shelves with pepper spray so
we can fight back
so why not focus on the primary concerns
and not the
voting bill that you masquerade as a
right spill people see through that like
cellophane over a fruit basket as for
ending the filibuster i gotta say i'm
with obama on this
the american people want less
partisanship in this town but everyone
in this chamber knows that if the
majority chooses to end the filibuster
if they choose to change the rules and
put an end to democratic debate
then the fighting and the bitterness and
the gridlock will only get worse
that guy makes sense he should run for
president
of course joe the unifier still uses
that issue as a divider and when called
out he acts like a four-year-old who
just broke his mom's favorite antique
lamp yes he actually did link any or all
opposition to old democratic racists but
this is a problem with playing the race
card it's memorable except to the person
who keeps using it especially with joe's
memory the only card he remembers says
do not resuscitate
in the presser he called mitt romney a
straight guy forgetting that he once
said this about mitt
romney wants to let the he said in the
first hundred days he's gonna let the
big banks once again write their own
rules
unchain
wall street
they're going to put you all back in
chains
a guy putting someone in chains doesn't
sound like the behavior of a straight
man to me joe
too embarrassing when i have to call
9-1-1 i lose the key kt
of course
joe doesn't expect you to remember that
smear if he doesn't
and then he questioned the legitimacy of
future elections so who does he think he
is hillary post 2016 who blamed her
drubbing on every russian since yakov
smirnoff where the hell is he of course
the press shares the blame again nothing
about crime as people get picked off
left and right by mad men on every real
issue whether it's crime covert or
inflation the dems flounder because they
put all their eggs in the woke basket
imagine if joe had focused a little on
immediate concerns and not what trend
did on twitter he'd be okay i wonder
what joe thinks
oh that feels good
hey
just soaking my feet after a marathon
yesterday
that's right i i i did a marathon i
didn't run one i didn't walk one i
talked one just ask the press
axios
time new york magazine they all said it
was a marathon just like we told them to
so it didn't matter what i said
matters
that i said it over and over for two
hours that's two hours all right and i
hardly made any mistakes and i only
sacrificed one country to the ruthless
jaws of mother russia just one little
tiny little uh
country so i'd be smiling right now
except my knees are killing me
and so from the rear view mirror of joe
biden's decrepit jalopy the one with its
turn signal on the past 50 miles that
other guy trump doesn't look half bad
north korea the peace accords the
vaccine being right on china well before
anyone else
compare that to joe with the supply
chain crime inflation food shortages the
border in record time joe took the u.s
and added the letters s and r
and even trump you know when he called
people names he punched up merciless on
political leaders organizations rich
elitists athletes joe only punches you
the american public after all he's doing
a great job and if you just don't get it
you're probably a racist bottom line
when you get to be joe biden you stop
sweating the small stuff like putting
your shoes on the right feet problem is
he sees everything as small stuff
notably your concerns and your pain but
it turns out he's the best thing to
happen to republicans since khakis and
chick-fil-a republicans don't have to do
squad and they're already more popular
than they've ever been
i don't know what that says either
except don't get cocky
hello
welcome
tonight's ghost thank you announcer
you're welcome the k stands for kathleen
and the t stands for tough former deputy
national security adviser kg mcfarland
he's seen more combat than the real
housewives of new jersey retired u.s
marine corps bomb technician and fox
news contributor johnny joey jones
he's like the stanley cup you're only
allowed to touch him if you're a hockey
champion
vice president of public relations for z
labs chris barron
[Music]
and finally she's like a toothpick
skinny sharp and easily fits into dark
disgusting places fox news contributor
cat time
kt welcome to the show always a pleasure
to see you
honor and a pleasure here yes you're
already worried aren't you
what did jose what did you make of the
uh the press conference and how did you
feel about the i guess the priority of
issues in general
i don't think you talked about what the
american people care about but my
concern as somebody who's a national
security person is he did basically
invite vladimir putin to move into
ukraine and it's the ripple effect that
that has so putin now has a green light
maybe not to send tanks across the
border but to do hybrid warfare which
will accomplish the same thing and then
biden tried to clean it up today yes let
me explain what i really mean yes i mean
invasion means armed units going across
the border but that's not what putin was
ever going to do cyber attacks hybrid
warfare false flag operations but what
this the really big problem is that
whatever putin does
you now will see china respond in march
you'll see north korea decide it's going
to get serious about nuclear weapons and
iran and the same now what does that
mean to the average person well maybe
you don't think it means too much but it
means big economic problems big
particularly big trade and and problems
coming out of china and when you talk
about the border which is one of the
things you're concerned with it's the
fentanyl that keeps coming directly from
china in an effort to kill off young
americans
like god i'm not an average person
[Laughter]
jonathan joey jones kt brings up the
cleanup have you been following this i
mean it's it is like a fight between
spouses and joe is the husband that said
that now has to apologize for everything
he said when he came home drunk
[Laughter]
yeah we all know this which he can't
remember by the way yeah it's like i did
not say that yes you did say that you
did say that i didn't say that did you
record it no i didn't have to record it
you said it
as three i think that happens
as three quarters of an above average
person yeah
i sat there and watched that with an
open mind i thought the press did a
better job than i expected they pushed
harder i mean when you ask the president
hey is there you know how do you feel
about the fact most people think you're
a little bit too senile to do the job
you know that was a good question
because that's how a lot of people feel
uh but you know i saw your colleague i
love him to death he's really nice to me
geraldo earlier a couple hours ago
and he bragged that joe biden stood for
two hours and i'm thinking there are
some people in government like brian
mass or tammy duckworth who get a little
bit of a slow clap for standing for two
hours those of you don't know that they
don't have legs right um but that's not
the kind of thing that we're going to
appreciate about a president in this
much hot water you know he says find a
president who did more in the first year
like i think zachary taylor did more in
the first year
than this guy and like you know and
what's funny about is anyone who you
know might have voted for trump said
they're like oh pick me teacher i'll
tell you all about a president who did
more in the first year um so i don't
know where he where he felt like his
firm footing was uh to keep on the leg
jokes but it wasn't behind that podium
it was good very
fun fact it's zac efron not named after
zachary taylor
not
not i know a lot of people thought i was
gonna say was
but that's why i'm here
chris amazing i know chris what about uh
the fact that he also believes like
trump that these elections are corrupt i
mean there was so much that he said
during that thing that i was just
imagining trump being up there and
saying something similar and the
meltdowns that would be occurring yes
like in real time jim acosta would have
set himself on fire during that if trump
would have said in advance of the 2018
midterms like yeah they're probably not
going to be legitimate knowing that the
republicans are going to literally
acosta would have set himself on fire
yes what's amazing to me is to the point
about like oh he's talked for two hours
or whatever he did that because he
thought that it was actually going to
show
the people who were questioning his
ability he thought that this was going
to be something good what he didn't
understand was that every second it went
on it got worse and worse and worse it
was like
the batteries were powering down yes and
that's what it looked like it like it
came out there and then it was like it
just started drifting off and the answer
started getting weirder and yeah
and it just i was like i know what he
thinks he's trying to do here he's
trying to show people that like he's up
to doing the job but in this effort he
is undermining himself so dramatically
because i can't imagine anyone who
watched that and thought man i really
feel good about president biden right
now we're going in the right direction
except jen rubin it is weird though you
know kat you've had a day to think about
this and i know you've spent a lot of it
just thinking about this and pride but
you know it's weird it's like
what chris said is i don't mind seeing a
politician or president even that's
incompetent because i'm assuming that
like that means maybe less damage will
be done but the problem is he's being
overrun by an entire wing so when you're
watching something that weak you're
going oh my god where's this country
going yeah
absolutely and the fact that
anyone would even praise him or he'd be
proud of himself for standing up for two
hours like that's not a campaign slogan
yeah i can't vote for me i can stand up
for two hours
well now if i ever run for office that
might actually be a candidate so
you know the point is you got to have an
excuse but i think that would be selling
anybody short right like i mean like i
like things about you more than that
it's a weird thing to brag about um joey
thank you for your standing yeah thank
you
but i remember okay intervention season
two there was this girl christy you
remember christy she was the tweaker yes
yeah the she's an alcoholic all she does
is just she's outside of reality she
smokes meth she trashes the house she
lives in a bunch of trash and during her
intervention you know what she says yeah
well i'm not dead so what am i doing
wrong
he was there and he did it and like he
was conscious it's like if you are using
the same logic as this deeply methodical
tweaker and i'm thinking you know things
that's not good no it's not a good it
isn't good at all all right well i think
we destroyed that topic hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else